[Musique]
il y à une liste qui n'attend pas les
sondages pour faire des bonds c'est la
liste dite de la loi naturelle que
roland sicard eric de l'agneau vous
présente elle est dirigée par benoit
frapper frapper le accent aigu surtout
ne les dérangeait pas ils peaufinent
leur plateforme électorale car le parti
de la loi naturelle c'est ça un peu de
méditation transcendantale beaucoup de
vols you geek comme ceux ci aient promis
tout va s'arranger pour bien faire il
faudrait que 7000 personnes veulent en
même temps on n'y est pas encore arrivé
mais le vol ionique tout est là il
suffisait d'y penser en matière de
criminalité nous faisons baisser
immédiatement de 30% la criminalité nous
en matière de chômage
nour développons la nour stimulons les
lois naturelles qui régissent l'économie
et renforçant la créativité le chômage
baissera de la même sorte en dom dans le
domaine de la santé mais pouvant faire
baisser les maladies de 50 % en trois
ans est notre programme en yougoslavie à
la guerre qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire la yougoslavie au lieu d'apporter
des ddm
des troupes armées qui coûte extrêmement
cher à la société
il faut apporter un groupe de cohérence
et à partir du moment où il y aura un
groupe de cohérence en nombre suffisant
la guerre s'arrêtera du jour au
lendemain plus guère plus de chômage
plus de maladies plus de crimes le
programme de benoît frappé à de quoi
séduire alors pour en savoir plus
l'équipe de france 2 fait un saut
jusqu'au village voisin
quarante huit heures de vol ionique
intensifs aurait-elle déjà eu comme
prévu un effet sur la population locale
est-ce que depuis deux jours vous avez
santé des ondes positives
quel genre aux études
là des ondes positives à aucun moment
non ça viendrait de quoi sinon du vol
rio geek je suis ma depuis deux jours
alors ça les gens ne posent pas vraiment
rien du tout on attend avec des
résultats comme ça beaucoup redescendre
et bien vite sur terre mais benoît
frappé et ses amis eux restent sur leur
nuage
après les européennes la présidentielle
l'argument est simple du parlement de
strasbourg à l'elysée il n'y a qu'un
petit pas ou plutôt qu'un petit bout
[Musique]